The amount of smoke coming
out of it, like a barbecue,
that is not something that you would see.
When it hits the ground,
it's actually really cold.
I am professor Gretchen Benedix.
I have been studying meteorites
and asteroids for about 20 years.
Today, we're going to be looking
at asteroid disasters in movies and on TV
and judge how real they are.
Now, we can get asteroids
that are fully metallic,
but they wouldn't be spiky
the way this thing looks,
with all the canyons and things.
The asteroids that we do see
do not have this kind of
debris cloud around them.
An asteroid will generally not have
too much of this gas coming off of it.
It may have some ice in it;
that's not going to be the majority of it.
I'm pretty sure that we would see
something that size headed for us
well before it got to that point.
Very unrealistic.
The biggest myth is
that you actually have
to steer your spaceship
to avoid asteroids.
There's a ton of bodies out there.
It's a huge amount of space.
It's really hard to get into a situation
where you might hit some accidentally.
You could potentially land on it.
It's not like landing on Earth.
You're dealing with a totally
different gravity regime.
You know, we've had a couple
of really tiny asteroids
that we've got missions
from Japan and the US,
and they have these
little touchdown things,
and it's really, really, really hard
just to do this tiny
little drone-size thing
and land it down on the
surface of the asteroid
and then get it back off.
The amount of power you'd
need to actually explode,
it is impossible.
We don't have enough explosive
material on the Earth.
So, there have been some studies
done that have shown that
if you take an asteroid
20 kilometers across,
you need something like
200 gigatons of explosion
to break that apart completely.
Now, the biggest thing that
we've ever exploded on Earth
was 50 megatons.
So you'd need 4,000 of those
to blow up something 20 kilometers across.
This thing in this movie
is 1,000 kilometers across.
You'd need 130,000 15-megaton bombs
to try and blow that
particular asteroid up.
A shock wave, it's a pressure sound wave.
You need atmosphere to have sound.
So when the sound is playing in the movie
about this explosion happening,
that's possible because there is a lot
of what we can see is atmosphere there.
So there's some gas molecules,
and that's going to cause
that sound wave to travel.
But it's space,
so usually there's a whole lot of space
in between all of these molecules,
so the sound is not going to
be what we hear here on Earth.
You will have a shock wave,
but it won't travel out
both sides of a thing.
It'll only travel out one direction.
That's not how you would actually try to
destroy an asteroid that's coming for you.
So I would give it a 1 out of 10.
65 million years ago
is not when the asteroid got knocked out
of the asteroid belt.
That is when the asteroid
actually hit the Earth.
No. 2 wrong, the asteroid
belt does not look like that.
It's not a doughnut of rocks
that are that close together.
Sometimes you can get an asteroid family.
So you can get one asteroid that has
maybe three or four other
asteroids kind of close to it.
So, this asteroid gets knocked out.
You can have collisions
every once in a while.
They do get the size of the rock correct.
Over time, the sizes of the
rocks that are out in space
have actually gotten smaller,
because they do run into each other,
but they're really far away from Earth.
So not all of them are going to get
onto a collision course with Earth,
and they don't necessarily
impart enough energy
to stick it on a direct collision course
to the inner solar system.
The collisions that occur out there
over time have gotten fewer and fewer,
because we've kind of gone
from a really chaotic system
4 1/2 billion years ago to
now it's pretty quiescent.
There's a mission called DART.
They're trying to take a small asteroid.
They're going to push it
with their little spacecraft
and see if it will change
its orbit in any way.
Then the movie takes a
different tact and says,
well, it missed.
The orbit was such that
it kind of got close,
but it flew by.
Now, we do have objects that fly by.
That's kind of cool.
And that, I don't think a 6-mile asteroid
would actually skim the atmosphere
and then bounce out again.
But you can do that with
smaller-sized objects.
Again, 1 out of 10 for realism.
I love this show.
And in terms of the realism
about everything else,
they actually use real
asteroid shape files.
They have coated it with material
that would make it hard to see.
The amount of light that's
reflecting off the surface
is the only way we can tell
that that thing is there.
So we can see it moving,
and if it's moving fast
and it's bright enough,
the amount of light it
reflects from the sun
is how we tell it's there.
So if they've coated it with
this coating that's stealthy,
then system that they have in place
to detect incoming
asteroids, that would fail.
So that actually makes sense.
I would be surprised if he
didn't hear it, to be honest,
because that would be a
very loud rumbly noise
that you would kind of notice
before you saw the light.
There have been fireballs
that have come across.
We get images of them,
and people don't hear them or see them.
Or sometimes people will hear something
but never see the fireball itself.
For this particular scene,
all of that makes sense.
You'd feel the thermal radiation
before you felt the shock wave.
That's definitely realistic.
So even if you're, like,
500 kilometers away,
you might feel the thermal
radiation in maybe a minute,
whereas you might not feel the shock wave
for half an hour or more, an hour.
And the effects of the thermal
radiation would be burning.
Your clothing could burn
off. Your skin might not.
But I imagine that it
would, it would just depend
on how far away from the impact you are.
So at least an 8 out of 10 for realism.
Pause on the comet.
Let's talk about that first.
There's this whole bunch of smaller bodies
in between Mars and Jupiter
that we called asteroids,
and asteroids are really
rocky metallic bodies.
Comets come from farther
out in the solar system.
Comets are composed
primarily of ice and dust.
The fireball that we're seeing here,
these bits of material
are fragmenting off,
and they are still moving fast enough
so that they can exhibit a glow as well.
That is a normal thing that you would see,
just not at this size and distance.
The size of this rock
is about the same size
as the rock that caused the
extinction of the dinosaurs.
So having shelters is a good idea,
because we know what that asteroid did.
We'd want to be underground.
Potentially could devolve into that level,
of governments making choices
about randomly picking people to save
and then finding shelters
for them to go into.
What we're seeing is that the entire Earth
has been wrecked and poisoned.
There would be potentially
a global dust layer
on top of everything.
But you would not
necessarily see the level
of shock damage or structural damage
that is being shown here for
every place on the planet.
You could potentially
have sunlight be blocked
for quite a while, and then
that could settle down.
2 or 3 out of 10.
We've never witnessed something this size
hit a terrestrial planet.
What we're seeing is the smoke trail.
We're not actually seeing the fireball.
And then an explosion.
That's not how it works.
It would be something
that is like a fireball
and then a trail of smoke behind it.
You know, we have evidence of this.
In 2015, this
several-tens-of-meters-wide object
came through the atmosphere in Russia,
and it fragmented,
and people caught the
whole thing on dash cams.
So, the impact itself
would potentially cause
a lot of material to come out.
I don't think it would
go straight up like that.
It would more spill out sideways,
and then the shock wave would come after.
Certain impacts can burst your eardrums
because of the airburst afterwards.
So if it's big enough, yeah,
you can get noise levels that are
well beyond breaking your eardrums.
And that's the way the cookie crumbles!
There's a trail,
a skidded track to the end of the trail.
No. That doesn't happen with impacts.
Impacts are an all-or-nothing thing.
Even if they come in at
a really steep angle,
it will still make a single hole,
and it won't have a gouge in
the Earth leading up to it.
That's gonna be a zero on this one.
Does that look like a problem to you?
Meteor shower!
They call this a meteor shower.
The size of that thing is not a meteor.
Those are big rocks.
And we now know meteors are really tiny,
small specks of dust.
So meteors are different than asteroids
and comets and meteorites.
We're talking about tiny dust particles
that are between the size of sand grains
to maybe a small pebble size
that are burning up in the atmosphere.
So this is a fireball,
or we could even call it a bolide,
if we're feeling super scientific.
If you see a fireball and it
looks like it's headed for you,
stand there until the
very last possible second,
because if it's small,
you might be able to jump out of the way.
But probably not.
And if it's big, it doesn't matter.
I get this a lot.
"I saw a fireball over there,
so it must have just landed
over on the other side of my field."
No. If you see a fireball,
it's actually really far away,
because it's very high in the atmosphere.
Woo-hoo, I'm on fire!
Woo-hoo!
You would not be catching fireballs.
And if a fireball hit you
like it hit those two,
you would be fried.
You'd be in the crater
that was left behind.
From the perspective of
science, it's not realistic.
So I give this a,
I think a 1 out of 10.
From the perspective of
a rock hitting the ground
that came from space,
yes, that's a meteorite.
Honey, bring your phone. C'mon, c'mon!
Don't go near it! Don't go near it!
It glowing on the ground,
no, that's wrong.
So that means there's
something inside of it.
It might glow as it's coming
through the atmosphere,
because the chemistry of the rock
might interact with the atmosphere.
So you could get
different colors that way.
Purple would tell you something about
the elements that are in it.
Meteors that glow different colors,
but again, those are just
small pieces of dust.
Smells.
The amount of smoke coming
out of it, like a barbecue,
that is not something that you would see.
A meteorite coming through the atmosphere,
it heats up, but only the outside.
So when it hits the ground,
it's actually really cold,
because space is cold and
it's been out in space.
And there have been reports
of people finding meteorites
very shortly after they've fallen
and them having ice on them.
And if you're going to get burned from it,
it's going to be freezer
burn, not a heat burn.
You can get close to them
as long as they haven't
come in at a massive speed.
Peekskill meteorite in the US,
October 1992,
the meteor was seen
across about 16 states.
It actually hit the boot
of a car in New York
and punched a hole through the car.
Did you plant those?
No.
It would not be something
that is actually alive
after having gone through
that atmospheric thing,
unless the meteorite
is somehow a spaceship,
which, generally they're just rocks.
The idea that there could
be life on a meteorite,
that's one area of study in our world.
We check for evidence
of either organic material
or the precursors of organic things
that could potentially harbor life.
We haven't found any so far.
So we've found precursor materials,
but no actual evidence of life.
The color,
it doesn't glow on the ground at all.
I'm going with zero out of 10 on this one.
This is the comet,
and it is hitting water.
The odds of anything hitting water
are really high on the Earth.
That tsunami wave looks very high to me,
but I think you could get a tsunami wave
that was something like 600 meters high
with the size of that object.
The running-away part, in general,
you're going to have some time
before the tsunami hits.
As we know from recent
events with volcanoes
in the middle of the Pacific,
it takes a long time for the tsunami
to get to wherever it's going.
If the impact is upon
you, you have no warning.
The only way that happens
is if we haven't tracked it.
And the only way that happens
is if we're not looking.
And so none of those things are happening.
You wouldn't have this
level of water coming inland
as far as I think this is.
So even if the impact had
happened very close to shore,
the depths of the water would be less,
so the wave would be lower.
This is completely ... no.
I would probably head for
the middle of a continent
if I knew it was going to hit water.
"Deep Impact," for realism,
I'd give it a 1 out of 10.
Why does the ephemeris keep
getting lower and lower?
Professor Mindy?
So, this is really good.
I like this aspect of it,
is we're going to run through the numbers
and we're going to do the calculations
from first principles.
0.0 means we're getting
close to the Earth.
That doesn't mean it's going to hit,
'cause 0.05 AU is still
farther away than the moon.
The way we currently check for things
that might be potentially hazardous
is when we do these calculations,
we work out, well, if it's going to be
closer than 0.05 AU from the Earth,
then we call it potentially hazardous.
There's a good chance it'll never hit.
So his worry is probably
not unfounded.
It happens several times a
year that you'll get something
at this 0.05 or less.
But generally, the sizes of the objects
are only a few meters or
tens of meters across.
This particular size comet
would not completely decimate.
It would not take out the Earth.
It would destroy it, but
it wouldn't break it apart.
It would make it a mess,
but it wouldn't even
wobble it off its orbit.
I think they said it's,
like, 10 to 15 miles across.
Even the moon-forming event,
which was a Mars-sized object
smacking into the Earth,
did not destroy the Earth.
The probability of something
the size of what these things show
actually hitting is so
infinitesimally small at this point,
because the solar system
has evolved over time.
So don't be afraid.
We're doing a really good
job of tracking things.
We have a much better handle
on how we look out in space.
Thanks so much for watching.
If you enjoyed this video,
click on the one above.